when I was a lad my old man would tell  me stories of magical places 'im tales  of far-off lands with golden haired  maidens and oath sworn knights  lands rich with drink and lavish feasts  I never believed those stories  until I found two so  this is a land left untouched by the  tides of war easily rivaling Valinor  odds Gallic in size into song simple  folk live simple lives they work the  fields peddle their goods and tend to  the vineyards making the finest wines  this side of the Ponte it's a land right  with opportunity full of wild beasts lay  maidens to defend and long lost  treasures just begging to be found here  a man never pangs with hunger never  wants for company and never goes  anywhere without a drink in his hand but  with all this debauchery and drink you  might wonder what brought the white wolf  to this land of  well I think it's time I told you a  story  abby's stalks us  pants us in the night  and only The Witcher  and shake us from this nightmare  you